thinking outside the box is the
prerequisite for innovation to break the
mold to rise above the status quo to
discover simple and clever solutions not
thought of by anyone else before and so
this treadling boss is absolutely not
that i'm sorry what the [ __ ] even is
this the straddling boss is a classic in
a long line of transit [ __ ] projects
that propose to revolutionize transit
usually through some wacky solution that
nobody ever needed or wanted before but
this didn't stop it from being included
among the 50 best inventions of 2010 by
time magazine so what exactly is the
problem with this straddling bus and how
is it connected to harry potter let's
find out after a brief word from today's
sponsor masterworks unlike the
straddling bus this startup is at the
forefront of innovation revolutionizing
a very lucrative yet very antiquated
market estimated at 1.7 trillion dollars
one that's more than double the
appreciation of the s p 500 over the
last 25 years while demonstrating zero
correlation to the typical investments
of stocks and bonds in other words the
returns have been above average and this
market moves on its own making it a
great way to diversify your investments
and reduce risk and preserve wealth but
what's even more exciting and relevant
is that when the stock market is down
and inflation is high like right now
this market increases in value even more
than normal the only problem is unless
you're an insider or a billionaire it's
been impossible to access i'm talking
about the art market masterworks has
used tech and finance to disrupt this
market opening it up to investors across
the world just as it's predicted to grow
another 900 billion dollars in the next
four years no wonder the nyt recently
celebrated orders bulletproof even in
the face of a stock market meltdown
mesterworks has a proprietary data set
of the art world so extensive that
they're asked by firms like city to
partner on reports on the global art
market and they select less than three
percent of the thousands of paintings
they're offered looking for those with
the highest historical appreciation and
stability then mr works acquires the
painting and breaks it into shares you
can invest in so diversifying with art
fits into your budget and you can
further diversify among different
artists and paintings the folks at
mrworks of course know what they're
doing their portfolio of 500 million
dollars worth of art is up 12 this year
on an annualized basis and their
investors have seen over 25 net returns
for the last four years in a row getting
started with masterworks is very easy
just visit the website create an account
and after a few clicks you can start
browsing to diversify your portfolio
with one of the most stable assets
around especially in light of the recent
stock market disturbances and climbing
inflation if you want to take advantage
of this and invest in some fine art
there is a waiting list however you can
skip it and start investing immediately
by clicking my link in the description
thank you for checking out masterworks
as like this helps about what i do and
now back to the video so the struggling
bus on the surface without thinking
about it for too long it seems like a
neat solution who wouldn't want to be
comfortably whisked along in a spacious
elevated bus above the soul crushing
bomber to bumper traffic who wouldn't
want to take part in this amazing
transit revolution well stay tuned i
guess the concept itself was first
unveiled in 2010 at the beijing
international high tech expo and by 2016
they actually built a functioning
prototype in the city of qinhuang dao
with 300 meters of track and a station
the idea was simple and appealing just
build two simple tracks on each side of
the road and then raise the body of the
bus above the cars passengers would
board at elevated stations along the way
the interior was rather spacious able to
hold around 300 people about the same
amount as two articulated buses crammed
full the idea itself is a new by the way
there was a concept like this before the
boss washed landliner only that would
have carried entire buses at high speeds
and then dropped them off as set
locations compared to that the
straddling bus was a more modest thus
more plausible solution people hailed
the straddling bus as a transit
revolution deeming it an innovative
solution to traffic but the straddling
bus was no revolution in fact it was the
ultimate embodiment of the status quo
allow me to explain first of all the
concept had some relevant problems that
were never solved that couldn't be
solved since they were fundamental
elements of the design the most obvious
problem is space this treadling bus has
to run on wide avenues with at least two
lanes per direction you cannot run it on
a normal two lane street because stuff
is in the way parking spots lampposts
signs garbage bins benches pedestrians
balconies even the system can only
function in areas that are separated for
the sake of current traffic this
severely limits potential areas of
service i guess what i'm saying is good
luck trying to build this straddling bus
in cities not ruined by robert moses
also the boss is seven meters wide which
assumes a 3.5 meter lane width which is
not always the case especially inside
cities often lanes are narrowed because
wider lanes lead to more speeding and
accidents so you can end up in a
situation where one leg of the
straddling bus is at the side of the
first lane while the other leg is in the
middle of the third lane also gotta love
how those wide deep rails go through the
crosswalk it'll be fun accidentally
stepping into it and breaking your ankle
a further problem is the bus itself it's
four four and a half meters tall which
is about the same as a regular double
taker bus so theoretically it should be
okay but the problems start when the
city doesn't normally operate double
decker buses and the infrastructure
isn't designed around such height on
their 3d render you can even see a
section of road lowered so the
straddling bus can pass under a
pedestrian overpass it's very silly and
you cannot really decrease the
straddling bus's height either the
maximum height of vehicles that can pass
under it is 2 meters or less that
basically limits you to personal
vehicles only as even most vans are two
meters tall so we do see the problem you
can't go higher because you will bump
into stuff and you can't go lower
because cars won't be able to pass below
you you're essentially stuck sandwiched
between two places you really don't want
to be and so imagine a common van like a
mercedes sprinter catching up with his
straddling bus the van will have to
tailgate all the way stuck behind the
bus blocking an entire traffic lane
defeating the entire purpose of having
his traveling bus in the first place or
maybe the van is in front stuck in the
traffic jam which means the treadling
bus is now also stuck in a traffic jam
by the way boarding was originally
envisioned through large lifts that take
a bunch of people to and from the
station in and out of the bus and that's
the giveaway right there that this
system was designed by people who have
no idea how public transit works if
you've ever taken public transit you
know how elevators are the worst thing
you can have if you're looking to
exchange a lot of passengers in a short
amount of time there is a reason why
subways primarily have stairs and
escalators other potential issues would
just be a pain in the ass what if
someone crashes into the legs of the bus
the whole thing would need to be shut
down traffic stopped and passengers
would need to be evacuated if this
happens while the bus is in the middle
you'll have to close down additional
lanes to allow passengers to reach the
sidewalk or you can just plop them onto
the road underneath i guess yeah just
300 people casually milling around on
the road underneath the straddling bus
right at the accident site neat also
about those people cutouts gotta love
how they put a grand total of four in
there just like how there are five at
the station four in the elevator and one
inside the bus transit [ __ ] projects
seem to work best when transporting very
few people it seems i'd like to see a
render of morning rush hour when 500
people are trying to get in and out also
do notice the cute cubicle in the wide
comfy chairs with armrests even compare
this to a seat layout of actual mass
transit designed for quick and large
scale passenger flows like a regular bus
and on regular buses half the space
isn't taken up by huge elevators either
as you can see this thrilling bus is not
quite space efficient at least the
prototype looked more like an actual
transit system which had normal seats
and didn't have the dumb elevators now i
know what you're thinking how is all
this connected to harry potter you see
the author she who must not be named is
a centrist liberal stay with me i'm
going somewhere with this and so in the
harry potter universe goblins are
second-class citizens centaurs are
viewed as beasts and are forced into
reserves discrimination against people
with non-magical parents is widespread
muggles are viewed as inferior wizards
have their own guantanamo prison where
they torture people and they keep
households as slaves voldemort and his
supremacist ideology are the embodiment
of these injustices he is the logical
continuation if you will this is
contrasted by the heroes and their more
egalitarian ideas the final fight
against voldemort is therefore not just
a magical duel but also a clash of
ideologies by defeating voldemort you
also defeat his supremacist ideas
changing society for the better but
there's a problem as i've mentioned the
author is a centrist liberal as such she
is deathly afraid of change actual
meaningful change thus at the end of the
harry potter series voldemort gets
defeated through some [ __ ] one
mechanics minutia and then it's back to
business as usual goblins remain
second-class citizens centaurs are still
kept in reserves magic guantanamo stays
open and households remain in general
slavery that's because jk rowling clings
to the status quo as if her life
depended on it she views it as sacred
and untouchable which then forces her to
awkwardly try and work around it instead
of making meaningful changes which is
the exact same thinking that went into
the straddling bus why do we need a bus
that glides above the road because the
road is full of cars well then how about
we take a regular bus and designate a
bus lane in each direction oh no that
would be traffic reduction we cannot do
that that would mean changing the status
quo of car dependency so let's just try
and awkwardly shimmy along the sides of
the road and build out all this
expensive infrastructure like elevated
stations because a few cars were in the
way by reducing car traffic we wouldn't
need expensive [ __ ] like these
overpasses either we could also get rid
of the inconvenience caused by traffic
congestion but instead we get this in
the beginning of their video occupying
resources of roads and with heavy
pollution referring to regular buses oh
but of course won't somebody think of
the road resources and heavy pollution
by buses don't look at the giant suvs
and big ass sports cars or that
kilometers long sea of corns in front of
you we need to take those damn buses off
the road lest we accidentally change the
car centric status quo by painting a bus
lane on each side which is the actual
solution to the problem these straddling
bus tried to solve just paint the damn
bus line in the end the straddling bus
of course failed by virtue being a
really stupid idea and also due to
complaints filed against the developers
by investors on suspicion of
embezzlement which ended in 32 arrests
it's almost as if this whole project was
just a grift to milk gullible investors
and potentially lend a contract with a
desperate local government almost but
now this treadling boss is back if you
can imagine only significantly dumber
the mastermind of this idea is dahir
insad which is apparently some
engineering firm hard to tell addressing
city mayors buy our system write to our
gmail for details slight upgrade over
the straddling buses hotmail address oh
no what is this channel oh no oh no
what is this
what is going on here what are you
buying honey
oh
[Applause]
oh yeah now the indoors version i too
like giving cashiers carbon monoxide
poisoning wait they don't even put your
bags into your trunk you just put it in
the passenger seat oh the flying train
of course it's like an airplane but it
also needs train tracks to function if
the christian interpretation of hell is
real then i'm pretty sure it looks
something like this
okay all right i think i'm done for
today thank you for watching and don't
forget to hit like and subscribe and do
check out my patreon if you wish to
support me making more content like this
and others as well and i'll be seeing
you next time